history has shown us that real
impeachment is nothing like the partisan
divide we saw this week in Nancy
Pelosi's house vote to formalize
procedures for the impeachment inquiry
the vote was 232 to 196 strictly along
party lines to Democrats however
defected and even voted with the
Republicans
it is so clear what's happening here a
vote to simply formalize the procedure
is by far the least partisan vote it is
benign if there were a scintilla of
evidence of an impeachable offense that
vote would have crossed party lines as
it did would Nixon and Clinton
prediction complete and total failure
ultimately in the Senate the Democrat
players here are dishonest disingenuous
and deceitful example Nancy says I'll
only do this in a non-partisan way if
and when the time comes before
impeachment will have to be something
that has such a crescendo in a
bipartisan way
she lied the woman is more than willing
to impeach in a partisan way as well as
divide the country in her power grab
from the rightful occupant of the Oval
Office and lying sack of ship is so
dishonest his law license should be
revoked he lies about the so-called
whistleblower saying we never talked to
him when they did he perjures himself in
Congress as he lies about what the
president said on the Ukraine phone call
he lied when he told us he had evidence
of Russia collusion he was cunning as he
created a narrative about Ukraine while
the deep state cultivated the so-called
whistleblower who reportedly isn't Obama
holdover who although not confirmed by
Fox News has apparently worked with Joe
Biden John Brennan
and Susan Rice just like there was a
collusion delusion these Liars created
yet another narrative so they could
impeach Donald Trump now whistleblowers
historically were required to have
first-hand knowledge but no the
Democrats just changed the rule now
hearsay can be the basis to take down a
president you don't have to see it
witness it or even hear at first hand
you can just mosey around and talk to
the other malcontents syn the west wing
who don't like Donald Trump and then
call yourself a whistleblower
now either ship is stupid or his ego is
so big that he doesn't know that a
president could only be impeached when a
high crime or misdemeanor occurs like
when a president has done something so
outrageous and so beyond the norm that
we as a nation say he no longer deserves
to remain in the Oval that he can no
longer be our commander-in-chief Bill
Clinton engaging in sex acts with an
intern in the Oval Office
while his president that's is about
disgusting an abuse of power that the
me2 movement has ever chosen to ignore
Richard Nixon was part of a conspiracy
that approved a burglary into the
Democratic headquarters at Watergate a
crime in and of itself in both cases
there was non partisan subpoena power
the president's attorneys were present
there was cross-examination and get this
Adams has a closed-door interview on the
day the Democrats voted to make the
process more transparent what a joke
this guy thinks he's an emperor and
they're probably telling him his clothes
are beautiful there are no rules here
this so-called formalizing the
impeachment inquiry puts the president
in a worse place than any other
president where impeachment was
attempted in Queen Nancy and Emperor
Adams world Donald Trump as fewer rights
in an ms-13 gang member illegally
crossing our southern border this is
outright lunacy with the liars and the
leakers and the leftists running the
asylum with radicals resisting not just
the president but the law the
Constitution and the Americans with this
man in office they take our laws and our
Constitution and they use them to
distort them for their own illegal
purposes and dammit they've gotten away
with it who the hell are these people
who flaunt the law and get away with it
and they even laugh about the fact that
their deep state is accomplishing its
goal I for one I'm sick and tired of
this nonsense I'm sick and tired of the
lies and the hate and the hypocrisy and
the lawlessness of those who hate the
man who every day fights for this
country I don't want to hear that secret
hearings are so going on I don't want to
hear that Schiff has the right to veto
the president's lawyer to veto or
Republican subpoena to veto testimony to
close the doors
who the hell does this guy think he is
who's blowing smoke up his ship no I've
been in California and Texas and Florida
in the last two-and-a-half weeks I have
literally spoken to thousands of
Americans every one of them wants to
know when these leftist criminals are
going to be prosecuted when there's
going to be accountability and Nancy
Pelosi for over nonsense about the
president not being above the law
stop the doublespeak Nancy it's you and
your gang of criminals who are above the
law and Bill Barr and John Durham better
be prepared with indictments or face the
wrath of America that for too long has
felt that they are held to a different
standard in the end this is only about a
conversation
that our president had with the
president of Ukraine and to be honest
with you it's none of your damn business
what was said we're not entitled to know
what Barack Obama was promising Putin
through Medvedev after the election in
that hot mic moment and we're not
entitled to know what the quid pro quo
of Barack Obama was when he gave a
hundred and fifty billion dollars to the
Ayatollah or are we just supposed to
assume he was playing Santa Claus with
Iran a phone call with the Ukraine
involves policy if you don't like the
president's policy vote for someone else
the guy on the other end of the phone
says there was no pressure the
transcript makes it clear there was no
pressure the guy on the other end didn't
even know military funds were not
available so how the hell can there be a
quid pro quo and I am tired of
protecting this whistleblower Barack
Obama fired the whistleblower and fast
and furious and from what it appears
this whistleblower is just another Punk
trying to get his leftist creds he's
nothing more than white no noise totally
irrelevant to the conversation which in
itself is the best and only evidence so
all of you out there get over it this is
a bunch of nonsense the Democrats are
tearing this country apart yet again
they are wusses and wimps and weasels
and they don't have the hutzpah to face
donald trump in november and i don't
blame them because he'll blow those
wusses wimps and weasels right out of
the swampy water that they call home and
that's my open let me know what you
think of my facebook page twitter
hashtag judge Janine